[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr de
lenski acusó a rusia de cometer torturas
en misión una de las localidades
recuperadas por las tropas de kiev en la
región de jarque en la ciudad continúan
las labores de identificación de los
cadáveres encontrados en fosas comunes
tenemos reportes desde el terreno
la esfera para dar un último adiós a la
reina isabel segunda ya supera las 16
horas y la fila está a punto de alcanzar
su capacidad máxima lo que significa que
cientos de personas podrían quedarse sin
entrar a la capilla ardiente- antes del
lunes cuando tendrá lugar el funeral de
la mano
las personas migrantes enviadas el
miércoles a la isla de martha's vineyard
en massachusetts por decreto del
gobernador de florida fueron trasladadas
a una base militar ron de santis
defendió su iniciativa mientras que la
casa blanca denunció el uso político de
la migración de cara a las elecciones de
medio término
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 en español soy rosa pérez
masdéu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en ucrania el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
acusó a rusia de cometer actos de
tortura en misión una de las localidades
recuperadas por las tropas ucranianas en
la región de jarquín a las puertas del
donbass las tropas rusas se retiraron de
la ciudad el pasado fin de semana y
dejaron al descubierto decenas de fosas
comunes
productos hasta el momento se han
encontrado más de 440 tumbas es
demasiado pronto para hablar sobre la
cantidad de personas enterradas allí las
investigaciones están en curso ya hay
pruebas claras de tortura de trato
humillante a las personas además hay
evidencia de que los soldados rusos
cuyas posiciones no estaban lejos de
este lugar dispararon a los ya
enterrados sólo por diversión el mundo
debe reaccionar ante todo esto
y el enviado especial de france 24 goool
y bergerac nos mandó el siguiente
informe con la situación sobre el
terreno inicio
algunos residentes de edición que
todavía no tienen acceso a internet no
saben que este sitio existe estaba
escondido detrás de las posiciones del
ejército ruso en los bosques a las
afueras de la ciudad pero el viernes
bajo los focos de los medios de
comunicación internacionales los
trabajadores municipales y los
investigadores iniciaron el sombrío
trabajo la exhumación de las tumbas
hasta ahora hemos exhumado unos 25
cadáveres verá como hemos terminado esta
fosa ahora envolvemos el cuerpo y luego
pasaremos a la siguiente y así
procederemos con nuestras
investigaciones hasta que hayamos
recorrido todo el territorio algunos
fueron enterrados con sus documentos
y estos miembros petrus otros
equipos estos eran soldados del ejército
ucraniano la causa de la muerte se
determinará sólo después de la autopsia
las explosiones son obra de las unidades
de desminado cercanas
los soldados parecen haber sido
enterrados en fosas comunes los civiles
individualmente los enterradores locales
dijeron que muchos murieron por las
bombas o los cohetes durante el asalto
ruso ahí sí um en marzo y fueron
enterrados de nuevo aquí más tarde pero
no todos
moscú se encontró una cuerda alrededor
del cuello de este hombre y signos de
que este acuerdo fue utilizada para
asfixiarlo lo que significa que puede
haber sido estrangulado
que no se puede ver en las imágenes es
la terrible sensación de muerte que
permea este bosque no se sabe
exactamente cuánta gente de aquí ni cómo
murieron lo que sí está claro es que
estaban vivos antes de que la invasión
rusa comenzará el 24 de febrero
por otro lado las tensiones continúan
alrededor de la central nuclear de
zamorilla la planta recordemos está
operada por funcionarios ucranianos pero
es controlada por las fuerzas rusas este
sábado de hecho el kremlin denunció
nuevos ataques de artillería hacia la
central lanzados desde zonas dominadas
porque hace el régimen de kiev ha
reiniciado sus provocaciones destinadas
a crear un posible desastre tecnológico
en la planta de energía nuclear de esa
orilla durante las últimas 24 horas se
han registrado dos ataques de artillería
lanzados contra el asentamiento de
cabañas de bolsa y una subestación
eléctrica cerca de la planta de energía
un total de 15 proyectiles de artillería
se han lanzado desde la zona de nikko
por las unidades de artillería de la
safa han sido neutralizadas por un
contraataque el entorno de radiación en
la central nuclear de esa policía sigue
siendo normal
continuamos en europa pero cambiamos de
tema vamos al reino unido porque las
autoridades británicas alertaron de que
el tiempo de espera para despedirse de
la reina isabel 2a supera ya las 16
horas la capilla ardiente cerrará el
lunes por la mañana poco antes del
entierro de la monarca por lo que la
fila está a punto de alcanzar su
capacidad máxima pero por otro lado en
países donde la jefatura de estado
también recae sobre el monarca británico
como es el caso de canadá la muerte de
isabel segunda ha reabierto el debate
sobre la legitimidad de la monarquía en
sus territorios pues el rey eduardo
eduardo séptimo es el bisabuelo de la
reina isabel todo es el pacífica desde
peacemaker tras el fallecimiento de la
reina isabel segunda la liga monárquica
de canadá está intensificando sus
esfuerzos para promover la corona pero
muchos quebequenses se muestran
indiferentes a su nuevo rey carlos
tercero y les aporta es muy importante
que el rey venga a canadá lo más amenudo
posible la monarquía necesita ser vista
por la gente para qué su papel su
importancia y su relevancia y comprenda
que esta conexión todavía existe en
esa conexión no existe para muchos
quebequenses que ven a la monarquía como
una imposición un ejemplo es el motín
quiere decir la reina en una de sus
últimas visitas a la provincia un sondeo
reciente mostró que el 77 por ciento de
los quebequenses consideran que la
monarquía es inútil y me tiene
completamente indiferente a este creo
que hay cosas más importantes y aunque
no no tengo ninguna opinión al respecto
no me molesta en absoluto que la
tengamos un ojo a dave a una monarquía
es como es genial es histórica pero
realmente no le veo valor en una especie
de sociedad moderna como la nuestra
especialmente una fundada en la igualdad
entonces podría la monarquía estará
acercándose a su desaparición según la
constitución canadiense es necesario el
consentimiento unánime del senado la
cámara de los comunes y todas las
provincias
si hablamos de jeaustin trudeau o
incluso de su principal oponente pierre
po alierta apoyan a la monarquía a nivel
federal no hay realmente un partido que
se centre en rechazar la monarquía como
vemos en australia así que es poco
probable que se produzca el
derrocamiento de la monarquía de
monarcas y no se podrá ver en nuestros
países de la commonwealth como jamaica y
australia hay un gran deseo de
emancipación al igual que en barbados
cuando hace menos de un año se convirtió
en una república
vamos a eeuu este viernes el gobernador
de florida ron de santis defendió el
envío de personas en situación
administrativa irregular a la isla
turística de martha's vineyard en el
estado de massachusetts
una inmigración irregular es nuevamente
campo de batalla en temporada electoral
tras haber sido enviado sin previo aviso
al balneario turístico de martha's
vineyard en el estado de massachusetts
estos indocumentados en su mayoría
venezolanos fueron trasladados por orden
del gobernador a la base militar de
kapkot preparada para situaciones de
emergencia defensores de los derechos de
los migrantes se les ofrecieron ayuda y
criticaron este proceder de las
autoridades republicanas del sur del
país puede ser irónico que esté mejor
aquí en massachusetts que en texas pero
la realidad es que nunca deberían
haberles puesto en esta posición porque
no se sabe que les pudo haber pasado
el traslado dio pie al gobernador de la
florida ron de santis para defender su
decisión de enviarlos al norte y para
arremeter contra la supuesta doble moral
de los estados tradicionalmente azules
con políticas más tolerantes con los
inmigrantes
esta es una política masiva intencionada
que está causando un enorme daño en todo
el país y todo tiene su origen en la
incapacidad de bailén de ocuparse de que
las leyes se ejecuten fielmente y de
cumplir su juramento así que en lugar de
preocuparse un puñado de gente rica y
porque tenga 50 inmigrantes y por cierto
ya los han echado ya se han ido dicen
que quieren a todos que nadie ilegales y
los sacaron en 48 horas
para la casa blanca al accionar de los
republicanos es claro usan a los
indocumentados como peones políticos de
cara a las elecciones de medio término
en the woman eran niños eran madres que
huían del comunismo y que les hicieron
el gobernador de santis y el gobernador
abdul de yuste me los tratan como bienes
materiales en un truco político cruel y
premeditado primer trade cubero constant
ya son al menos 10.000 inmigrantes los
que han sido enviados desde texas y
arizona trasladados a territorios
controlados por demócratas como nueva
york y washington
puerto rico y república dominicana están
en alerta meteorológica el centro
nacional de huracanes de estados unidos
avisó que la tormenta tropical fiona
puede convertirse en huracán a su paso
por estos territorios del caribe durante
las próximas horas el fenómeno ya pasó
por la isla de guadalupe como tormenta
tropical
muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en france 24 y frank 34
punto com enseguida volvemos
[Música]